♪
>> JERUSALEM IS THE SEAT OF
ISRAEL'S GOVERNMENT.
TODAY WE FOLLOW THROUGH ON
THIS RECOGNITION AND OPEN
OUR EMBASSY IN THE HISTORIC
AND SACRED LAND OF
JERUSALEM.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BY RECOGNIZING HISTORY HAVE
YOU MADE HISTORY.
WE ARE IN JERUSALEM AND WE
ARE HERE TO STAY.
>> ISRAEL IS THE SOVEREIGN
NATION WITH THE RIGHT TO
DETERMINE ITS OWN CAPITAL.
THE SAME RIGHT THAT IS
ENJOYED BY EVERY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
>> WE ALSO WITNESSED TODAY A
CEREMONY OF THE PRIME
MINISTER OF ISRAEL AND THE
ADMINISTRATION OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP THE PEACE PRICE.
BURYING THE TWO STATE
SOLUTION KILLING THE HOPE OF
THE MINDS OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE MIDDLE EAST OF THE
POSSIBILITY OF PEACE.
>> Bret: IT WAS A CAMPAIGN
PROMISE AND IT HAS BEEN
DELIVERED.
THE U.S. EMBASSY MOVED FROM
TEL AVIV TO JERUSALEM.
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE
FOLLOWED SUIT OR IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS THE FIRST
ONE BUT GUATEMALA THIS WEEK,
PAIR
PARR
PARAGUAY DEMOCRATS
SUPPORTING.
THIS CHUCK SCHUMER, THE INTO
THE MINORITY LEADER SAYING
LONG OVERDUE MOVE MOVED
EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM.
EVERY ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO MOVE ITS
CAPITAL.
I SPONSORED LEGISLATION TO
DO THIS TWO DECADES AGO,ENED
I APPLAUD PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR DOING.
SO OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAD A REAL PROBLEM WITH IT,
INCLUDING MANY PALESTINIANS
TOOK TO THE STREETS TODAY.
SOME 40,000 PALESTINIAN
STAGED DEMONSTRATIONS ALONG
THE BORDER, MORE THAN 50
PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN THE
RIOTING THERE.
25 WOUNDED AND SOME OF THE
ARAB STREET WEIGHING IN ON
THAT AS WELL.
BRING IN PANEL STEVE HAYES
EDITOR AND CHIEF FOR THE
WEEKLY STANDARD MARCH A
LIASSON "NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO."
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY SENIOR
EDITOR AT THE FEDERALIST AND
WE WELCOME FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY SPOKESMAN MICHAEL
ANTON.
MICHAEL, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
THIS WAS THE PLAN FOR A LONG
TIME.
HAD IT GONE AS PLANNED, DO
YOU THINK?
>> IT'S MORE THAN A CAMPAIGN
PROMISE.
FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS U.S.
LAW FOR, I THINK, 23 YEARS
PASSED IN 1995.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
I THINK DRIVES MIDDLE
AMERICA, THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN CRAZY ABOUT
WASHINGTON.
CONGRESS PASSES A LAW WITH
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
PUTS A WAIVER PROVISION IN
IT SO THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
THROUGH THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES IS THAT THIS
SHOULD HAPPEN.
AND EVIDENCE SIX MONTHS
EVERY PRESIDENT WAVES IT,
WAVES IT WAVES IT PRESIDENT
FINALLY FULFILLS THE TERMS
OF THE LAW AND YOU SAW THAT
YESTERDAY.
HE GOT SOME SUPPORT AND A
LOT OF HIS POLITICAL
DOMESTIC POLITICAL CRITICS
YOU KNOW LEVEL ALL KINDS OF
ACCUSATIONS AT HIM WHEN I
THOUGHT AS THE TERMS OF THE
LAW THIS IS BIPARTISAN
CONSENSUS FOR TWO DECADES.
>> ON THE BIGGER PICTURE,
MARA, ON THE MIDDLE EAST
PEACE PROCESS AND WHERE THIS
GOES, WHAT DOES THIS DO TO
THAT?
>> I THINK THAT'S THE BIG
QUESTION.
KIND OF NOW WHAT?
IT'S NOT UNLIKE GETTING OUT
OF THE IRAN DEAL.
OKAY, NOW WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO NEXT IN THE MIDDLE
EAST PEACE PROPOSAL FROM THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS YET
TO BE UNVEILED.
AS YOU HEARD, THE
PALESTINIAN LEADER THEY ARE
NOT INCLINED TO ENTER TALKS
NOW.
THEY FEEL THE UNITED STATES
IS NO LONGER AN HONEST
BROKER.
IT'S JUST TOTALLY ON
ISRAEL'S SIDE.
SO I THINK NOW THE BALL IS
IN THE PRESIDENT'S COURT.
AND HE HAS TO COME UP WITH
THE NEXT STEPS FOR MIDDLE
EAST PEACE IF THAT'S WHAT HE
WANTS.
IF HE JUST WANTED TO FULFILL
A CAMPAIGN PROMISE, HE HAS
CERTAINLY DONE THAT.
>> Bret: MOLLIE?
>> I THINK IT IS AWFUL TO
SEE WHAT WE SAW THE LOSS OF
LIFE WITH SO MANY
PALESTINIANS BEING KILLED
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST"
HAD REPORTED THAT THEY WERE
TOLD THAT HAMAS HAD TOLD
THEM THAT ISRAEL WAS NOT
MANNING THESE SITES ON THE
BORDER AND IT WAS CAUSING
PEOPLE TO RUSH AND IT WAS
FOUND THAT THEY WERE MANNED.
THAT IS SAD TO SEE.
IT'S NOT FUN TO WATCH.
IT IS ALSO TRUE THOUGH THAT
I THINK THAT THIS COULD, IN
THE LONG TERM, LEAD TO A
GREATER CHANCE FOR PEACE.
WE HAVE THE REALITY THAT
JERUSALEM IS THE CAPITAL OF
ISRAEL.
AND IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
EVERYONE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
AND IT'S TIME FOR
PALESTINIANS TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT AND THAT DEALING WITH
REALITY IS A GOOD WAY TO GET
MOVE FORWARD TOWARDS A PEACE
AGREEMENT WHICH PEOPLE HOPE
FOR.
>> Bret: STEVE?
>> THERE ARE OTHER THINGS
TAKING PLACE BEHIND THE
SCENES AROUND THE
SUBTERRAINIAN LEVEL THAT
SUGGEST THAT THERE IS SOME
MOVE TOWARD PEACE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
TALKS THAT ARE HAPPENING OUT
OF PUBLIC EYE.
BETWEEN ISRAEL AND THE
SAUDIS OR THE SUPPORT-OUT
THE COMMON VALUES ON THE
IRAN DEAL BETWEEN ISRAEL AND
THE SAWEDIES, U.S. AND UAE.
THE BAHRAINYS STEPPING UP
AND SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE IRAN DEAL.
THIS GETS A LOT OF HEADLINE
US PARTICULARLY BECAUSE OF
THE LOCALS OF LIFE THERE ARE
OTHER INDICATIONS THAT ARE
MUCH MORE POSITIVE AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT DONALD
TRUMP CAMPAIGNED ON.
THIS SOMETHING THAT HE SAID.
I THINK MIKE IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
HAD PRESIDENTS OF BOTH
PARTIES SAYING FOR LITERALLY
DECADES AND THEY DIDN'T DO
IT.
HE DID IT.
>> Bret: THE EQUATION OF
PULLING OUT OF THE IRAN
DEAL, THEN MOVING THE
EMBASSY AND THOSE TWO THINGS
TOGETHER, HOW DO THEY
INTERCHANGE?
HOW DO THEY INTERLOCK?
HOW DO THEY AFFECT EACH
OTHER?
>> WELL, THINK THAT I, FIRST
OF ALL, I JUST WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON A POINT THAT
STEVE MADE THERE.
I THINK WHEN YOU MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY, I DON'T THINK
THIS IS REALLY THE
PALESTINIANS MISSING THE
OPPORTUNITY.
REALLY THE PALESTINIANS THAT
NEED TO COME BACK TO THE
TABLE.
THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT
HERE.
IF THE PALESTINIANS, IF
MAHMOUD ABBAS WOULD COME
BACK AND TALK TO THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
PRESIDENT AND SIT DOWN, I
THINK HE WOULD FIGHT
INCREDIBLE WILLINGNESS AND
EAGERNESS TO GET A DEAL
DONE.
I HAVE HEARD PRESIDENT TRUMP
TALK ABOUT THIS SOME TIMES
THERE SAN OLD SAYING GOES
AROUND WASHINGTON PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DEALT WITH THIS ISSUE
THAT THE PALESTINIANS NEVER
MISS AN OPPORTUNITY TO MISS
AN OPPORTUNITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
DOING NOW.
I THINK IT'S ALSO
INTERESTING THAT WHAT YOU
ARE SEE SOMETHING A LOT OF
THIS IS COMING OUT OF GAZA,
WHICH IS CONTROLLED BY HAMAS
AND RUN BY HAMAS, RIGHT?
AND YOU ARE NOT SEEING THIS
INTENSITY COME OUTS OF THE
WEST BANK.
THIS IS CLEARLY BEING GINNED
UP FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES
AND THE WHITE HOUSE IS SO
CONCERNED.
LOOK, WHAT'S ONLY A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE HOSTED A CONFERENCE ON
THE FUTURE OF GAZA AND HOW
TYPICALLY PROVE ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF THE PEOPLE.
GOT THE GULF ARAB STATES TO
SHOW UP AND, YOU KNOW,
PLEDGE SOME AID.
THESE ARE STATES THAT DON'T
LIKE TO TALK TO ONE ANOTHER
IN SOME RESPECTS BECAUSE OF
THE DISPUTE IN THE GULF.
AND DON'T LIKE TO BE IN THE
SAME ROOM WITH ISRAELI
REPRESENTATIVES.
AND THEY WERE ALL THERE.
I THINK THAT WAS NEVER
POSITIVE AND HOPEFUL SIGN.
IF ONLY THE PALESTINIANS
WOULD EMBRACE THE
POSSIBILITIES THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS OPENING UP FOR
THEM.
>> Bret: I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS DOES THE ARAB
STREET CHANGE NOW BECAUSE OF
THE DIFFERENT RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THE GULF
STATES AS FAR AS HOW THEY
REACT TO BOTH THINGS, THE
IRAN DEAL AND THIS MOVE?
>> THERE IS -- DOES SEEM A
RESHAPING IN THE MIDDLE EAST
FROM WHAT WE HAD SEEN IN THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION WITH
AN EFFORT TO MAKE IRAN MORE
DOMINANT AND THE I-BUT I
THINK IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN
HOW THEY RESPOND.
>> Bret: MARA?
I COME BACK TO THIS QUESTION
IF THE UNITED STATES IS
GOING TO BE THE LEADER AND
IS GOING TO PUT FORWARD A
PEACE PLAN THAT NEEDS TO DO
THAT.
THE PALESTINIANS WILL COME
TO THE TABLE IF THEY SEE A
GOOD PLAN WHERE THEY THERE
IS SOMETHING IN IT FOR THEM.
RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT IS.
>> FOR YEARS, MIDDLE EAST
PEACE HAS BEEN USED AS
SOMETHING TO BLOCK PROGRESS
IN OTHER AREAS IN THE
REGION.
IF R. YOU KNOW THE FOREIGN
POLICY ESTABLISHMENT SAYS
YOU HAVE TO SOLVE MIDDLE
EAST PEACE FIRST AND THEN
YOU CAN ADDRESS THREATS FROM
IRAQ AND ADDRESS JIHADDISM
AND IRAN AND ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS.
I THINK THIS SENDS A MESSAGE
PRETTY CLEARLY THAT'S NOT
GOING TO BE
GOING OO BE
GOING OBSBE
GOING OBSTACLE ANYMORE.
TAKE THAT AND SET TE'O SIDE
AND DEAL WITH THREATS FROM
IRAN ON REALISTIC.
>> Bret: CHANGES THE
PARADIGM AND STARTING POINT?
>> BRIT SET IT EARLIER IN
THE SHOW YOU ARE DEALING
WITH REALITY HERE.
MORE REALISTIC LOOK HOW THE
MIDDLE EAST SUN FOLDING.
KEEP IN MIND IRAN IS A BIG
SUPPORTER OF HAMAS.
A LOT OF THE WEALTH THAT
IRAN IS ABLE TO TAKE IN
BECAUSE OF THE IRAN DEAL ON
FROZEN ASSETS AND THE WEALTH
THEY WERE ABLE TO GENERATE
BY BEING ALLOWED TO DO
BUSINESS WITH COUNTRIES THAT
USED TO SANCTION THEM, THEY
ARE SPENDING THAT TO
DESTABILIZE THE MIDDLE EAST
AND FUND TERROR.
FUNNELING TO HAMAS AND OTHER
GROUPS LIKE THIS.
HOPEFULLY WITH THE U.S. OUT
OF THE IRAN DEAL.
PERHAPS SOME NEW SANCTIONS
AND OTHER SECONDARY
SANCTIONS GOING BACK INTO
EFFECT, SOME OF THAT
RESOURCE FUNNEL GETS CHOKED
OFF, GETS REDUCED AND IRAN
DOESN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES